thank you
[Music]
[Music]
all right
we got something just poked its head out
of the Ravine there
got a bunch of caribou
and I've got a big ass bear coming in
I got a bear over here and I got Caribou
over here
he's actually quartering North so I'm
sure he's trying to get around without
giving a scent Trail up he's damn close
to Camp so that's not safe to me
my name is Susan Akins I am the sole
resident and owner of Havoc River Camp
it's an old oil Camp 200 miles above the
Arctic Circle I'm the only refueling
station and I do it on my own
in order to run a business I have to
cater to the people in the season that
they're roaming around
that summer and in that June July and
August I need to make enough Revenue to
support the camp and get ready for the
next year I am working 24 hours a day
and then boom winter hits
I've got nine months of some of the
harshest conditions on Earth and for the
nine months or more that I'm totally
alone out here I hunt for the meat that
I eat I live by my wits and sometimes
those are lacking the older I get the
slower I get but the animals keep
getting faster but I rise to the
challenge every day it's a challenge
that keeps me going
welcome to Kavik it's where I live
[Music]
I think what I'm gonna have to do is try
to get down there down the road a little
this way if I scare all the Caribou I'm
going to scare the bear as well
either way I've got Caribou to get and
there's a bear
it may be a twofer
welcome to Winter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay every Caribou is staring at me
where's my
it's like he disappeared off the planet
I've got to get a little elevation here
okay they're all coming towards me so
the bear must be on the other side
starting to push
Bear Tracks but this is a pretty big
bear he's not a juvenile long stride
this is just
King Mama Jama sloth and his way through
but I gotta get jamming
frustration right here
I'm trying to get the easiest place to
get at this bear in a 100 open field
without giving up 100 of my opportunity
at
whenever you're hunting bear the longer
you take
even seconds they're gone
your Hunt is blown before it's ever
started but I gotta try though
yeah
they're cruising now for the river which
means they're in migration mode
but it's possible that the bear is up
there I may just sit put and just see
what develops
[Music]
the bear across this open ground there's
no way I'm going to sneak up on them he
heard me he didn't smell me but he heard
me he probably saw the vehicle I don't
have the tracks on the vehicle all I'm
going to do is end up getting stuck
somewhere and no way to get myself out
that's not smart hunting
bummed out about the bear but not so
bummed out I'm gonna put my life in
jeopardy chasing them down
that just that's a Fool's errand
all right Mr bear
live to see you another day man
subsistence is basically just being able
to make a living from the land with the
things around you and we do a pretty
good job with that and we mix it into a
modern 21st century
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we got one good one let's get another
one
what's up little guy
you rolling up on us seeing what we're
doing we're making you a sled we can
make you a sled Tata and Carol gonna
make you a sled
I'm gonna make a sled for Wade it's
gonna be something you can play with for
a few years it'll be substantial it'll
be kind of a big sled but over the next
few years it'll probably grow right on
into it and plus just to be able to drag
him around would be a lot of fun too
[Music]
I'm Edward Hailstone my friends call me
chip I'm Mary dagness Hailstone
here in Norfolk Alaska
[Music]
we pretty much leave us in my nomadic
lifestyle we just go from area to area
depending on season we're Hunters
gatherers Fisher people I'm hunting in
the same areas that my parents had
hunted for hundreds of years
we got seven kids together three of them
still live with us the four of us have
grown up moved off we pretty much try
and teach our children
at my my pair
my father learned from their parents
it's very important for me to pass down
my knowledge to my children and to their
children
[Music]
okay what we need to do is go inside
since the sun's heading down and I think
actually what I want to do first is bend
the boards I want to bend you know what
I mean come on grandson let's go inside
the house and go work on your sled
follow us
here you go
you gotta walk on your own crazy boy
open the door for Tata Hold Us open hold
it open thank you
Carol check this out yep first thing
that we're going to do is make the
runners all right we're just gonna start
steaming these things and we'll be able
to put
foil over it to catch this and as soon
as these are nice and soft right here we
just have to make a Bend up about year
far and we can make a slide about that
big just perfect for a way to do a thing
for a couple years this will do
basically we're just gonna let all this
stuff cook
should we do the next step now yep we'll
start shaping the different pieces
Carol yeah sitting on this so you would
really help me a lot
it's always good to do activities with
my dad because like I get to learn
faster grab me the um the small diameter
threaded in
my Daddy has fun teaching me see what
you can do with that love it's real
useful here knowing how to build and
being with my dad and doing a one-on-one
work it's pretty fun
I love it
[Music]
oh my God these are good come here bun
I'm gonna pull this off we're gonna take
these two ends right here
and put them in there I'm gonna ease
them down this way if we hear any
cracking if we see any lifting and we
stop okay the runners have to be bent
and it's kind of a delicate process when
you bend them together they're a match
pair you can't duplicate a another Bend
so so the trick is to just do it right
the first time as best you can and make
your bins carefully and listen and feel
when you do it so ready let's give this
a try
are you sure you're gonna bend it down I
am sure exactly what I'm doing okay stop
that's all right
okay there we go there we go there we go
there we go
gently
okay I don't hear any Madness
now go choke up these two together these
two right here okay right there's
perfect absolutely perfect tighten it
that's good okay that way they have the
same bin in the same place at the same
time
same bat Channel we just have to let it
dry now all right that's all we can do
so we're done for tonight we're done for
tonight this needs to dry and tomorrow
we'll uh we'll take it off there when we
have everything else prepared and this
will be the last thing that we Mount and
that we fit everything to all right
[Music]
wherever you are they're dangerous if
you don't want to take a risk don't get
out of bed in the morning
but the reality is that knowledge will
protect you from the dangers in your
environment
[Music]
about a thousand feet above Lake
elevation here there's the camp I can
see it
see it Amelia
I got my own airplane this summer
the nearest road to 60 mile walk from
here if you want to get somewhere you're
not going to drive you've got to fly or
you've got to walk those are your two
choices
[Music]
before dark winter hits Glenn villeneu
and his family returned to their cabin
in the Brooks range
Glenn will hunt for a bull moose an
important supplement for his family's
diet
[Music]
okay landing gear is up for water we got
four blues can you check on your side to
make sure it's up because
looks good on my side first thing I do
when I fly into Camp I always like to
make a Passover the cabin look down see
what's going on
anytime I leave Camp even like now when
it's only for a couple of weeks I have
to check things out when I get back
because things happen when I'm gone
that's when bears are more likely to
come into the yard that's when things
can get damaged that's when things can
cause problems
I didn't see anything from the air I
want to get up to the cabin I'm going to
look for smaller details things can
happen here that I can't see from the
air
I don't do what I do because it's easy I
don't do what I do because it's hard I
do what I do because I have a lot of fun
doing it everything's a choice I chose
to live in the Brooks range I choose to
hunt for my food and now I choose to
have an airplane it all goes together
for me
my name is Glenn villeneu I live in
Alaska I moved up here almost 20 years
ago because this is the only place in
the world where I could live this
lifestyle I'm living
I built a cabin in Fairbanks I got a
place in the bush and I live half the
time in each of them
there's no other place on this planet
Earth where I could live the way I live
here
I'm in control of my own destiny I
decide where I'm going to go when I'm
going to go there what I'm going to do
nobody's telling me what needs to be
done I just see what needs to be done
and I do it
family's growing I had a new baby born
last summer I got four kids down
it was always my dream to have my family
in the bush with me it took time to
achieve that
and there were times when I had to set
the priority on being out here even
though I didn't have anybody to share it
with
I spent a whole winter out here by
myself but it gets Lonesome I mean I'm
only human
now I got everything I want I got the
Wilderness plus I got my family with me
made it back to the camp
looks good yeah everyone looks just like
hey dad looks like the meatballs knocked
down
what happened here
our meatball got knocked down this has
never happened before
there are not many things that can reach
up there and knock that down that's been
up there for 10 or 12 years
wooden pegs snapped right off it's only
one thing that could have done that
exactly
there's not a bear behind every Bush but
there are bears around
look something walked right here
that's a bear track headed right up
toward the meatball
this here looks like a sow with a cub
and they can be very defensive if you're
out here playing in the yard and all of
a sudden the saw with a cub walks into
the yard you could get into a dangerous
situation you got to keep your eyes open
well I better get to work fixing up this
meat pole because I want to start moose
hunting tomorrow
why don't you go back over to the cab
and open it up and get a fire going if I
can get this all fixed up this afternoon
then tomorrow morning I'll go out and
start looking for a moose
[Music]
every year out here you know I just grow
and I learn how to be more prepared and
ready next season
[Music]
all right
now we've got an amazing time of year
here definitely waiting for winter to
get going
right now we have some pretty strange
weather going on and it's uh just hasn't
froze up and it's more later in the year
than ever seen
so got some Open Water here on the
Slough back behind my house and I got a
little time where I could go out and set
some beaver traps
while I'm out there I'm definitely going
to take my gun with me because I'm going
to be covering a lot of country today I
might see some rabbits or Grouse or even
Ducks along the riverbank
so looking to go get some traps set but
also come back with something fresh for
my frying pan
I'm Jesse Holmes I'm a professional dog
musher I'm very blessed to live a
subsistence lifestyle I'm the banks of
the Nina River
when I come to Alaska I didn't know
exactly what I was going for I was just
going for something different and you
know I didn't expect to become a
competitive dog racer
now I'm here and it's become a huge
blessing and it's allowed me to live the
lifestyle that I envisioned
I chose to live this way because I
appreciate Simplicity and I cut wood all
water
dogs procure resources it's just
incredible to me I love it out here
I personally don't think you're ever
ready for winter
I never know what winter has in store so
I don't try to second-guess Winter all I
can do is just be in a really good
mindset have my mind clear ready for
what winter is going to bring
transition time of year
you can't really get out and travel
because nothing throws up and it's not
really good boating but really it's a
good time of year to make the best out
of the last of fall here like I'm gonna
go up the slough now the water's dropped
and I can actually access the slough
I'm gonna go see what's going on
yeah this looks real good definitely
some active Beaver sign around here
that's a pretty good sized feed pile
there might be four or five Beaver
around here so once I get over there
I'll be able to find where their main
exits are
set up all four of these traps the more
traps I put in this area the better
likelihood I got a catching a beaver
[Music]
the traps that I'm going to use are
lethal
things live right now
they're not only lethal to the animal
they're very dangerous to yourself if
you mess up when you're setting them
they're designed to crush bones
these traps are very effective once they
trigger this it kills them
it's got so much power but that power
could be a problem if it sets on me
trap set
up feed house and now I'm looking for
one last spot to put this one
so I'm going to set this one kind of
right in the edge of the water here
I've never tried to do this before but
trying new things is what keeps you
learning you know
see if maybe this works there's some
bait behind it
hit some right when it's coming out of
the water you might walk right into this
here
[Music]
all right I got my last trap set it's
looking good I still got plenty of
daylight here and I'm going to do is cut
across this Slough and get into the
woods and see if I can't come across any
rabbits Spruce Grouse anything that I
can eat
for me it's a mission to get a beaver
but a lot of things are out moving in a
hustle getting ready for the winter to
come
right now is this time where you're
waiting for freeze up to come it's
looking like it might snow today and it
might be my last chance to be able to
see some rabbits
the whole thing about hunting rabbits
right now is they're white on this dark
ground normally they're white in the
snow but it's kind of a late winter this
year
so the chances of seeing them is way
greater
right there's a rabbit I see one
got it
wait oh I see another one
got it I got two rabbits
getting two rabbits down when I was just
trying to get one that's called a two
for one and that gives me a real good
feeling I still got plenty of daylight
the rabbits are out
[Music]
in here I literally had to crawl to get
to the rabbit
all right there it is
man that is a beauty
he's fat I'm gonna throw this in my pack
go over get my other rabbit
I'm in kind of a hurry right now because
it looks like the rabbit hunting is good
right now and the snow could fall
tomorrow and I won't be able to see him
like I can now
okay I see the other one right over here
luckily it's not so thick right here
that I gotta crawl
wow that's another nice looking rabbit
man these guys are in really great shape
right now
this amount of meat is going to make six
meals for me
so far it's been a really good hunt but
I'm trying to keep my eyes out
there's rabbits all over right now
I still got about an hour and a half of
daylight left I'm gonna hunt until it's
as dark as it can be
[Music]
foreign
shop but if I go in I'll probably scare
him so
it's great I got a third rabbit this
one's even fatter than the other ones
this is just such a good resource right
now I didn't get to come away this fall
with a bear or a moose and I didn't get
to put the kind of time I wanted to go
out big game hunting but just knowing
the land around me and using the
resources around me I've been able to be
successful with lots of small game
still got an hour of daylight left I'm
just going to keep moving make the best
out of this resource while I can
[Music]
any interest in obliterating the species
in my ecosystem but I don't have any
interest in being obliterated
[Music]
I have to get past this area
can I even get across this
[Music]
nope
they cannot go that way
[Music]
with bear tracks near Cavett River Camp
Zoo continues her perimeter check to
gain a different perspective and observe
the Caribou migration as her window to
hunt is quickly closing
tracks I'm looking at the snow really
shows who's walking around your
neighborhood much like the silt does but
besides the tracks I've got to watch out
for all these drifts I no longer have a
clear line of sight where my ditches are
it's a little hazardous
I'm right at the top end of not being
able to use the Argo to go do these
things right you know anymore
all righty and all this is prime
territory for uh a bear
I'm not really seeing anything that
screams hey I'm over here I'm hiding out
come shoot me
since I'm not seeing a lot of signs up
here I think if I were a bear and I'm
thinking like my opponent I might get
down into the riverbed
couples tend to use the river
as their highways as do people I always
say get in the river if you don't see
anything get in the river it's probably
running the Southern Bank so it's time
for me to get in the river and run the
Southern Bank see if they're running
around
I can see from here
that there's quite a bit of water
flowing still
a little leery getting too far out
I think if I'm gonna surprise the bear
at this point I've got to do something
he doesn't expect the last thing this
bear would expect me to do is to be
floating down the river I got a new raft
and it's an Avenue I haven't tried and
why not I'm not going to go for a 30
mile Trek I have a perimeter that I see
as an area that's viable for me to worry
about what's running around in it
within two miles I definitely have my
hackles up within a mile to a half mile
I've got to be all over it yeah but at
five miles it's knowledge
but for me this is simple get in
float down and just see I'll be able to
see it I'll be able to tell what
direction he's going if I don't see any
of his tracks going this way then he's
still on my side of the river
and I'll have to take mine to that so
the plan for me right now is get a
little red get the raft get it together
get in the water
get some information
[Music]
holds for the Next Generation
all we can do right now is just teach
and teach and teach and care and love
[Music]
yeah this pile
yeah yeah that one's a good we just need
like two of them
while chip and Carol build
transportation for Wade Agnes and
daughter Edie Source materials to make
another essential tool to survive the
Arctic winter
today me and Edie are going out back and
picking out some Caribou skins and we're
going to be turning them into a parka
Far Away Kelly over in skin and beaver
skin and two Caribou skins it's getting
cold out and the conditions for
traveling is coming up and we just want
to prepare ourselves for winter so wait
Kelly will be just as warm as us when
we're out there with our parkas
okay
we're gonna have to turn these two skins
into the back front wooden sleeves yeah
we cannot mess up when we start cutting
because we have only these two skins for
right now
ready who's gonna be the marker or the
pencil go you are
no mistakes
the Parker we're going to be making is
traditional what you know what our
ancestors used out here
it's gonna take a lot of stress off my
mind knowing that he's a lot warmer than
he would be with these store-bought
jackets you know that weren't made for
this kind of winter
[Music]
could you pass that knife back to me
please be careful okay
be really careful
foreign
we have to start being careful until we
put all the trims around it so it just
doesn't keep ripping these trims are
what's going to hold it together once we
get thread and stuff all around it'll be
good
okay now let's get back together
[Music]
it's important that we all work together
and
um of course it's a family effort to
just prepare ourselves for winter and
I'm glad the family is all doing
everything they can to prepare for
winter
that almost looks like a park yeah
already yeah
I mean we still have a lot to sew but
then guys we're already halfway is done
[Music]
I love sewing it's one thing I could sit
down and do all day you know once I
start sewing I don't like stop until my
projects are finished but I do have a
son running around that doesn't need
taken care of
yes it's your parking
we work on your parking so you won't be
cold well your time to work on your sled
it's a surprise sled
and it's a surprise Sparky they do sit
down as much as they can and I saw what
I can and a lot of times he understands
I'm busy and he allows me to sit down
and sew but a little boy like that needs
a lot of attention
[Music]
there you go go check a few times if you
need help
laughs
so I'm just gonna finish up I just got
one little patch left to go for the
sleeve I'm almost done sewing the
armpits and then I could sew on the
sleeves and then I could help you with
the hood while she works on this
Wolverine raft it's a lot of work but
work isn't work when you're having fun
made with much love or await Kelly by
his Anna his mama and his auntie yeah
now let's go we can do this
you don't want your meat to get away
just go to the store and buy it
if you want the challenge of having to
outsmart the animal to get your meat
come out here and hunt it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at the break of dawn
Glenn heads out into the Brooks range in
hopes of harvesting a bull moose a
successful hunt will provide Glenn and
his family with an ample source of
protein necessary to make it through
dark winter
ice already
a couple more weeks the Lake's going to
freeze right over
Fall's my favorite time of the year
because there's a lot of action
everything's going on in the fall time
Winter's coming soon moose are rutting
that's the time to hunt this is really
when it all happens
this is the best time of the year and
this is when I go out and get the
biggest animal that I hunt all year long
I see a couple of moves looks like
they're both cows
confident with those two cows right
there that doesn't fall not too far away
Bulls are a little more wary though
there he is that's the wall
Sailors up towards me
he's got at least three cows
there's no way I'm gonna call him away
from those cows I gotta go down there
and pretend I'm another ball that wants
to fight him in order to get to Maine
with those cows that's my only chance
you've got to learn how the animals
behave
and as much as you learn and as much
experience as you have
you're still often at a disadvantage
because the animals are actually very
smart and they're very well adapted to
evading Predators these moose are
getting hunted all the time they've
evolved to escape from predators and I'm
the predator
they're completely adapted to evading
these
I've got to adapt
succeeding in catching them
there's some moves right up there ahead
I'm going to take my Handler off now
pretend I'm on full that might get the
ball interested he might come out and
try to chase me away
this antler works I've caught a lot of
moose with this antler
when they get close enough to see it
it often draws them right in it fakes
them up they see this antler
and they think I'm another moose
I've got to fake this moose out make him
think I'm in other moose
let's break it
brush is pretty high he's gonna have to
get real close
for me to get a shot
or Walk This Way slightly I'll get them
as close to the lake as possible
[Music]
there it comes I see him
[Music]
Sam he's right there
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
he's down
got him
oh that was pretty intense
I called him right out into this open
area I could see him but he didn't have
a very good view of me behind this tree
right here
just waving that antler and that's about
all he could see
I thought it was another moose
it's a good spot
close to the lake
not too far from Camp I want to call up
trition
family come over they've never been at a
moose kill site before they're going to
love this
Trisha
just got a moose
and he's not too far from Camp you can
come over
the outlet
all right see you in a little while
I'm so glad I was able to get this moose
close enough to Camp the Trisha and the
kids could come over
foreign
right over here
you made it your first moose kill this
can be great for them and we've been
talking about this for months they're
really interested in hunting they want
to see how this works
and they've never been able to come over
to a moose kill site before
look at this moose it's beautiful
got a nice sized ball I've never been
this close to most
moose
actually look it's a moose
don't touch it
no she shook her head no she said no
it's okay it's dead
animal food
okay I gotta get to work on this thing
what do you think of me you want to help
me cut this moose out what I really want
is the back strap okay I do the things I
want to do in life but as much as I
enjoy doing them I enjoyed even more
when I have people to share it with
I'm gonna pull on that a little bit
oh that's heavy yeah
foreign
's been here in Alaska now for four
years and she's picked up a lot just by
being around me operating out in this
environment she notices things
hey Amelia the main thing is by scooping
The Blood Out carefully I can preserve
some of the fat in there better
keep everything cleaner
[Music]
I think what's really important for
children isn't so much the practical
skills that they'll learn out here
although there'll be a lot of them
but it's just the attitude and the
mentality that develops because living
this lifestyle you get a lot of
confidence you get a lot of Independence
and you can take that wherever you go
a lot of my classmates don't realize
that how much work it takes
to get all the food they it's not like
you just go to the supermarket and get
your food people have to grow it pick it
process it
before it gets to the supermarket
hey Amelia
I'm gonna cut the tongue out this should
be tasty huh boiled tongue you want a
little moose tongue Agatha
everybody in the family likes tongue
all right
got it tongue
it's a delicacy that's going on the
first load
[Music]
first load down
[Music]
Glenn I think we're gonna head back
I think we're gonna head back she's
getting a little fussy good idea close
to bedtime yeah it's already getting
late
I got to keep working on this but you
can head home and
get a fire going and I guess
you're gonna go home and get a little
sleep now it's been quite a long time
over here at the kill site huh
yeah
see you when I get there
see you later see you Amelia
it's coming apart
slowly but surely
[Music]
before somebody puts that little thing
across my body six foot under the ground
I want to know that I climbed every
Valley and looked over every Hill
[Music]
this is the the Sioux raft
the monsoon I've got this bear that I've
been after
found some tracks out this way
went out after him but all I'm doing is
pushing him so for me my thought is I
want to get into the river the Argo is
blah blah blah blah blah I'm making a
lot of noise
this will be hopefully a lot less noise
it's a chance for me to try it out and
see how it works so this is actually a
trial run and a bear run
ready to go
let the winter bear sneakathon start
[Music]
Bear's going to hibernation
Zeus desperate to locate the predator
and tries a new tactic to gain a
different perspective
my objectives from this float it's uh
I'm looking I really want to see if I
see signs is there evidence that he's
still here
every year we lose people on the rivers
here
that is not 70 degree water or 80 degree
water
that's hovering right above freezing if
I fall in with that icy water I'm done
for it
a little nervous about getting on this
ice come on
okay
turning
okay
I have a perimeter that I see as an area
for me to worry about what's running
around in it
I'm not gonna go for a 30 mile Trek I'm
gonna go within reason of Camp I want to
see the five miles around camp
I'm just getting to the area where I
think the bear
you know is kind of his hangout Zone
the Caribou kind of came through this
way and they just thundered right past
this area
I think uh I think I'm going to start
seeing more signs
whoop whoop that's hella fast
turn in
come on get control Susie
ah come on
I have a big problem
I'm having troubles now
[Music]
I got him
that was uh
a little intense Maybe
um not bad just I'll have to work on
maybe how I want to place the oars in
the seat and everything when I'm right
in the middle of the faster water and
I'm doing this uh
it's really difficult
I'm seeing a few Caribou tracks there's
another set right there it looks like
they came this way and went yeah not
today and went back don't see any bear
prints here
but I want to get out and check
here we go
well this is kind of the area that I saw
the Caribou tracks and this is the first
place I can pull over you've got a wide
shelf it's a great spot if you're a
predator to Ambush something and eat
dinner
I can see some tracks here and here
already
looks like I got some foxies this is
very definitely Wolverine right here
I'm seeing a lot of good activity here
what it isn't is a bear
everything here
wants to survive and it's a tough
environment to do it in then this right
here just says it all you've got the fox
looking you've got the Wolverine looking
maybe a small wolf and caribou and you
know I'm looking for Bears there's a
bear pushing everybody around earlier so
I think what I want to do
my daylight is fading I'm gonna get back
to the Sioux craft I don't want to be
caught out here at night because I'm the
tables of turn doesn't matter if I'm
holding the gun if I can't see what I'm
shooting in
[Music]
do I feel safe from the bear I feel like
I want to be vigilant the moment you let
yourself go to lacks out here it's gonna
be the death of you
if he's a problem if he's absolutely
Rogue he'll visit me and I'll deal with
it then
[Music]
living what does living mean means I
ain't dead I'm healthy I'm happy and I'm
home it's all good
[Music]
come on Carol let's have a look see
I think these have been drying long
enough
you look fine to me they look the same
that worked out very well
continuing to prepare the youngest
family member Wade Kelly for the harsh
winter elements
Agnes Edie and Ting work on a caribou
skin parka
while chip and Carol start to assemble
the sled after bending the runners
well the next thing to do is to put this
together and we can glue it we can drill
it
okay yep and we can start putting our
tie downs
so if you want to get all the small
parts and bring them up here to the
table we'll start putting this thing
together
[Music]
we'll mark all these properly let me get
a pencil yeah please Carol's got a very
able-bodied uh helper right now she's
not somebody have to talk twice to I
don't have to watch her she's been in a
wood shop in school she's had the basics
down on making these kind of stuff she's
also saw me for years doing it too and
she'll be able someday to do all this
stuff herself
so he's gonna love this gift isn't he
Carol mm-hmm I'll probably get to read
it too I'm sure you will
he's gonna think we made him the best
little toy in the world I bet
looking good
looking real good Carol
[Music]
you can see how these are gonna go right
yeah
well this is the tuna liter you know
what it does here really well is that
it's springy so we can tie it really
tight as tight as we possibly can and
it'll it'll give just a little slight
ever bit but it won't let things break
so energy kind of passes with this stuff
and we'll tie this whole thing together
we'll work from the back forward okay
yep
[Music]
people been making kids toys for forever
caveman probably a big ass Rock he like
beat things to death with give his kid a
rock you know what I'm saying so that's
how I look at it
I want to make the kid happy if uh that
sled is beautiful in the eye of that
Beholder then I'll be glad Wade can play
with the thing and then they can always
throw him on it and drag him around it
ain't gonna be so small it'll be fragile
I'm gonna make this sucker tough
[Music]
okay we are done
let's clean up
wasn't that worth just the time we put
into it yep
a good little sled
okay I'm gonna go set this out there and
try not to let Wade see it so he doesn't
want to play with it yet making things
is how we've made a living you know
instead of buying sleds we've just been
able to attain wood put some work into
it make sleds so if you really want to
have the best you'll make it if you want
to have it at all you'll make it if I
want my grandson to have it I'll make it
foreign
[Music]
on them or a pack of wolves you never go
find a moose out here in this country
dying of old age
that's just all part of the natural
cycle
yeah
yeah
there
Glenn has successfully harvested a moose
providing his family with a Winter's
worth of much needed protein
with the meat processed he now Begins
the back-breaking task of transporting
each large segment home before Darkness
Falls
I got it
that's the last piece I had to separate
there
okay I got my moose all cut up
thankfully Trisha Amelia and I came over
with a sled
one of the biggest challenges of moose
hunting is just getting the animal home
after I get it down I got an awful lot
of weight to move
first moose that I ever moved out here I
carried the entire thing on my back 11
loads
and my back was in such bad shape after
that I laid in bed for about five days
couldn't move then I got smart I got a
sled the next year a simple thing
plastic sleather sure can help out
ah there's the canoe
so far so good well I got hundreds and
hundreds of pounds here to move
I can get it to where my family can make
use of that
until I broke my sled
that neck is the heaviest most difficult
piece of meat for me to get in the canoe
only way I was able to get in there was
to drag the whole sled in and I broke
the sled
not very nice hopefully it's still going
to be adequate to get the rest of the
meat down
but
that's what I got to deal with
this sled is necessary for me to get
this moose Out of the Woods without it
I'm gonna have a big problem
my sled's a basic piece of equipment
straight up there with my rifle my knife
my canoe basic transportation
I got eight or nine loads to go
hopefully this thing holds up
[Music]
there
looks like my sled's in three pieces now
but it's still helping a lot
broken size better than no sled
really my biggest concern at this point
is just getting it back before any big
scavenger finds it I mean there are
definitely Bears around and walls are
wolverines if any of those animals find
this meat before I get it all back in
the camp
they'll destroy it what I gotta think
about is getting the job done before
anything else gets to it this thing's
falling hard
falling hard
this light came apart
oh boy
this was busted right in half now this
is gonna be a problem
sled broke things happen you got to find
a solution
I gotta make some kind of emergency
improvisation here
see what I can do
if I can just get this the next 75 yards
down to the shore
I'll have a full canoe load I can go
home
I got another sled there I can bring
back over problem is just getting this I
I can't lift it up and carry it across
this tusaki ground down to that beach no
way
but I might be able to do something here
that's the biggest piece
put a hole in there
if I just shingle it like this
I'm taking the two biggest pieces
overlap them
try to lash it back together put the
heaviest part of the meat right here in
the front have the hoof dragging out the
back I think I might be able to make it
to the beach that way
a lot of times I've been in difficult
situations and not had much to work with
but if you stop think about it and use
your head
you can find the solution
hey it's sliding
it's a funny thing I've been doing this
for years
and every year it's difficult you have
to wonder like why am I making getting
food so complicated
but after it's all done and you're
sitting down there eating that
tenderloin you forget all this pain is
suffering it all goes away so fast when
you bite into that first juicy steak
there's nothing that tastes the same as
meat that you hunted yourself and put
the effort into getting back home and
putting on the table
there
okay
you get attached to your tools out here
I get attached to my tools because I
depend on them so much this sled right
here I've had it for years I've moved
literally thousands of pounds of meat
with this sled
and that's the last load of meat this
sled's ever going to move
we shared some pretty good times
together
I've been working 18 hours
I gotta grab a bite to eat and Camp get
a little rest and get back as soon as I
can before anything gets that meat
I've always operated alone so I'm used
to taking that risk
I enjoy the uncertainty that winter
brings and I enjoyed just stepping up to
the challenge of whatever it brings
an hour
getting my dog food uh cooker loaded up
with some wood before I head out to go
check my traps and see if I got any
action out there
set some traps a couple days ago so
hopefully you got something in those
traps
the temperatures dropped so definitely
going to probably be seeing a lot of
changes out there and a lot more ice
definitely feels like Winter's finally
got here get this fire going here and uh
that way my dog food will be cooked this
evening whenever I get home and uh
kind of the start to every day around
here get a good routine going and then
you can be able to afford some time to
go out and hopefully get some Beaver
right now
[Music]
it's a good time of year to be able to
be out watching what these Beaver are
doing if you don't get out and look
around you just don't know what's out
there
opportunity is all over out here you
just got to get out and go out and find
it I mean when I go out there in the
woods opportunity tends to cross my path
and I'm the type of person that takes
advantage of that
I see some movement up there
looks like a growth I've been trying to
get a shot at it with my 22 here
got it all right man awesome I haven't
seen many Grouse around this year come
out here to go check my beaver traps
brought my gun with me pound the grouse
with the snow being on the ground and
this bird being dark it stuck right out
to me you know and I was able to see it
out of the corner of my eye moving just
like I was the other day using my
surroundings to my advantage with uh
hunting the rabbits because they're
white on dark ground this is the reverse
of that clean organic meat right here
this is the best this is just a bonus
for going out here to check my traps
this is going to be delicious if I eat
this first thing tonight
[Music]
one of the things that I love about
living out here is you just get out in
the backyard and you start putting in
some effort and you can come away with
something to eat and that's a very
pleasurable feeling it's a valuable use
of my time I love to just go out and
walk and Hunt opportunity presents
itself Come Away with a bird to eat
getting close over here to my first trap
hoping to get at least one Beaver would
be real nice
trap number one
the moment of truth
oh nothing in there
we're gonna go check the other ones
definitely froze up overnight hopefully
those beavers came out for one last
snack on the bank where the size froze
up
yep nothing in these traps here
this is trap two and trap number three
nothing in there still got one more trap
to check I'm going over to check my Fork
trap it's not like the other three traps
I put this one under the water so it's
under the ice so there's a way bigger
chance that I'm gonna have a beaver in
this set than these other sets because
these beavers they can't come out up on
the bank anymore with this ice so oh wow
there's definitely some broken up ice
over here
I might have something in this one my
trap is under the ice right here
we can't really see underneath this it's
frozen pretty thick
there's the Trap
this is definitely my highest hopes for
having something in this trap right here
here's the Trap and there's nothing in
it
I thought we had warm enough weather
that this ice wasn't going to develop
this ice right here prevents the Beavers
from coming up into my traps that are on
the bank about in one more week I'll be
able to walk out on this ice and I can
set some traps underneath it that I know
are going to be productive I know I'm
going to get these beavers at some point
I come out here and I found a good
location that's a good thing to have in
my back pocket and know The Tout here
with the way the conditions are right
now there's no point in leaving these
traps here these traps aren't going to
do any good here so I'm going to Spring
them take them home
didn't come away with any Beaver but as
soon as that ice thickens up I'll be
able to go out there and reset those
traps right now I've got you know some
nice rabbits to cook up and nice Grouse
I picked up on the way and I'm about to
have myself a meal looking forward to
going home and having a nice fire and
cooking up some of this fresh meat
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
just this one rabbit and this Grouse
here will be a couple days worth of food
putting in the effort come out with the
reward now I get to enjoy the reward
here and
give myself some fresh rabbit
hmm that's good real good my grandpa
really liked hunting rabbits I feel like
if he was here he'd be real proud the
way I'm living
it makes me feel good
this is a real transition time of year
here it's going to be winter real soon
really just gotta adapt to living by the
cycles of the land here you know in the
seasons and know where the animals are
know when you can get them
one of my biggest beliefs out here
that's really helped me with everything
is to devote yourself to the Perfection
of whatever it is you pursue
to pursue everything with hard work
dignity integrity and persistence
maybe sometimes I have a little luck but
that luck is a residue of design
every time I go out there things are
going to happen but I got to go out
there and make them happen and I enjoy
that kind of Lifestyle
that's a lifestyle that always keeps you
on your toes always keeps you moving I
had my trials and my tribulations but I
kept coming at it and kept coming at it
and here I am now learning every year
how to thrive and survive more
vision of what I wanted to do to live
off the land
hunt for my food
live in the wilderness
and the Brooks range is the place
[Music]
weighs about 100 pounds
not a big head
after hunting a bull moose Glenn places
the final piece on his meat rack
culminating in a Winter's worth of
protein for himself and his family
there
got the meat hung up air can circulate
around it this is good it's already
getting a dry crust
and that's the key to preserving me
this meat's going to be okay
that meat's not going to spoil as long
as it's kept dry and clean hang in there
with good air circulation around it
it'll be just fine until it freezes
it's a chunk of fat right there
what an awesome hunt walking around this
Lake looking for this moose
unbelievable gorgeous country
I sure got my exercise it was a lot of
work
this is the payoff
[Music]
all right let's have some dinner
yeah it's finger food
Moose tongue
of course
[Music]
most tongues spent a year
it makes me think of the first time I
ever got a moose out here and uh
I put so much energy into it hunted for
about two weeks got a moose and I was
just sitting here enjoying all the
different tasty tidbits for the first
time
but I was all by myself
didn't have anybody to share it with
this is so much nicer having you all
here
a little bit more oh my God she's
totally into it more and more and more
Show Mommy what you want
isn't that good Agatha yeah Mustang
it took a while to get it all together
but you know this was my dream
that's what I always wanted to do live
out in the wilderness with my family
one of my basic philosophies in life
know yourself know what makes you happy
and then pursue it
and that's what I did here
I wanted to live in the wilderness I
wanted to have a family out here and I
have it
I have everything that really matters to
me
no matter where you are home can be the
coolest place on the planet of the Earth
but it's good to get outside and get a
stretch of the legs
[Music]
[Music]
but I've got my tarmigan in there the
oil it's actually Bear fat that's
rendered down some spices I'm adding
some spinach from my garden I take it
and I freeze it
these are some mushrooms I got earlier
in the year
it was a good day
[Music]
did I fail at killing the bear taking
harvesting the meat in the fur yes 100
but
is it really a failure no no I got my my
little Sue craft out got it together
went down the river in it got a whole
new perspective there's definitely
Predators up around and walking walking
the riverbank
a little white wine
some for the bird
some for me what did I learn out of the
whole event I better keep myself
prepared
I want to live this lifestyle for a long
time I've got to remember
you gotta be prepared it's not just for
the moment you got to be prepared for
anything nature always wins here
[Music]
I want my kids to take what they've got
and start their own I don't want to run
them out of the house but I keep
encouraging them I want them to succeed
[Music]
Wade come here wait mama want you your
Park is done these last few days we've
been putting all our attention toward my
grandson we just put a Parker together
and Chip and Carolyn built him a sled
and
um it's good just to see my whole family
help raise up my daughter Eddie's son oh
wow
it looks real fluffy too
you don't need to worry about you yep
nobody can worry about you when you're
wearing this oh
there he is
[Music]
really good he can pull his arms in and
if you had he's ready to pull these cups
down yep he's ready to go out there and
put your boots on right here
I've got a sled out here
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
try again me and Carol got together and
we made him a little sled and then the
ladies took some skins and threw
together a nice little Parky and when
the Deep cold comes he'll be able to
travel and stay with his mom and dad no
matter what the temperature is we'd
never worry in the world
so that's what you want for your
children give them the best make it
yourself if you have to
one more could a little kid want and as
long as you can give a kid a little
something you know let them know you
appreciate them
they'll enjoy it I don't know if he
knows the concept but
he'll figure it out
he loves it even your parka has Eskimo
it's very important for me to pass down
my knowledge to my children and we all
work together on this project and we all
just managed to put it together in major
parka that fits the boys so perfectly
and he'll be nice and warm and
everything she was made with love
come on get up make room for me
wow even and he could fish
it's
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um it's always great to see your all
your own kids really happy he loved the
parking he's going to use it all winter
and all of our hard work came together
and it made a really great parking that
my son will love and appreciate and
we'll have for a very long time just
the perfect parking for the perfect boy
he's gonna drag anywhere away
well we'll let them play on oh yeah you
guys go inside yep
we'll be inside making lunch okay I'm
gonna play out here for a bit
growing up going back and forth to Camp
you know I grew up learning a lot of
traditional and cultural ways of doing
things I've grown up where I've eaten
the cultural food and I grew up
healthily and happily off those kinds of
things for my mom to be able to teach me
something like making that perky it's
you know it's touching I love that I'm
able to do something like that and be
able to make it as beautiful as we all
made it turn out to be so I'm really
thankful for the way that my parents
have raised me and I'm thankful that I'm
able to pass that on to my son
foreign
[Music]